[Music]
i think i have an idea how to draw boba
fett out
with episode seven of the book of boba
fett officially in the bag that marks
the end of this chapter of boba fett and
fenix shan's saga but was it a
satisfying finish to the story and what
did star wars fandom think of the book
of boca fett as a whole be warned
spoilers for the finale up ahead this is
e.t canada's nerd
pretty much the whole episode is the
showdown between boba fett with his
allies and the pike syndicate and yes
there's plenty of spice in the
proceedings courtesy of director robert
rodriguez who's been an innovator in
on-screen action throughout his career
that being said coming off of the
previous two episodes which played like
a mini mandalorian season 2.5 and are
regarded by many as the best in this
series the shift and focus of this
finale felt a bit off the most of the
best and most memorable moments
understandably featuring mando and grogu
i mean that reunion alone might have
been worth the price of admission
okay little guy
i'm happy to see you too
he's wearing little shirt like it was
one so yeah no one steals the spotlight
from baby yoda but boba fett did get his
shine on here teaming up with din riding
the rancor and that final face off with
his former mentor cad bank
don't toy with me i'm not a little boy
any longer
you are an old man
i'm still faster than you
as cool as much of this was star wars
fans seem to be divided over whether
this episode and even the series as a
whole has been something worth raving
about some have said that the show
lacked the charm and energy of the
mandalorian while other hardcore fans
have praised it for its use of
characters from other star wars series
like the previously mentioned bounty
hunter cad bane if you look to rotten
tomatoes it tells a very similar story
with the audience waiting for the book
of boba fett sitting at a decent 61
and by comparison the mandalorian has an
audience score of 91
now if you're watching the finale hoping
to see some wild revelations or shocking
guest appearances you might be
disappointed what it does do is give us
a pretty clear picture of where we'll be
starting off with the mandalorian season
three with the dynamic duo of din and
grogu back together again whether we'll
get a proper season 2 of the book of
boba fett or if the former bounty hunter
simply pops up in the many new star wars
series to kick butt remains to be a
scene also you can only hope for a book
of coban
what were your thoughts on this finale
and the whole series did it live up to
the hype or were you left wanting
something different let's talk about it
in the comments below whatever the case
as is tradition i'm sure star wars fans
will be discussing and debating the
merits of this show for years to come
i'm carlos bustamante see you next time
you